bene lo disse basta rese oggi giocheremo
nuovissimo gioco super divertente in cui
saranno tantissimi scherzi il gioco si
chiama gesti wings che sarebbero meno
dovrebbero essere i figli di scary tc e
quindi sono cattivi e si fanno un sacco
di scherzi a vicenda quindi noi siamo il
fratello minore e dobbiamo fare gli
scherzi al nostro fratello maggiore
penso che sia super divertente comparirà
anche scheri teacher magari che seguendo
un bel mi piace se volete altri gameplay
consigliate sì pure qua sotto a quali
altri giochi volete che giochiamo
mettetevi comodi pop corn e primo
livello scritto tuo fratello rom non
gioca più con te quindi diamogli un po
di fastidio
prendi il cuscino quello che fa le
scoregge filo nel divano così ron si
sederà
vedi cosa succede ok allora lì in alto
nella camera potete vedere
ron il mio fratello sarebbe allora
prendo subito preso il cuscino
ora devo metterlo prima che arrivi che
si sta muovendo
queste sono quei turchi stanno venire
l'ansia ma con il cuore devo scappare
velocissimamente prima che vi trovi ok
che siamo salvi e ora vediamo che
succede qualcosa di un tendone si chiama
luca e cosa fanno
abbiamo completato il primo livello
possiamo al prossimo speriamo che gli
scherzi diventino sempre più cattivi
dice buoni fargli del male un pochettino
prendi il granchio dal muro grande come
vi pare
dal caso screen dall'acquario
a metterlo nella sua vita molto grande
tutti mi fa bene a questo brown che
poverino perché ho preso il granchio
allora dai co i pasti apriremo la carmen
dove già prima non mi chiama dorme con
la pizza a fianco prima si mangia la
pizza quesito infatti come fa capiamo ok
ma voglio la mia ma lo svedese ha detto
chi lo pagherà per questo con grande in
mano
allora si è scritto che sta per fare un
bagno mio fratello quindi io devo andare
a mettere la polvere eva si occupa
aspettiamoci lui sta arrivando già oddio
tutta la stanza forse questa è questo il
bagno
non faccio questo ecco la polvere e
mettiamo l'acqua
ok lo mettono la vasca ora devo andare a
nascondermi eletto in ascolto ma in
camera da letto
spero che non mi meta centrando con un
bagno proprio quello che mi serve
che cos'è questo colorito è stato luca
sa fare questo per la forza dedicata
alla fine noi nei prossimi oscar
prossimo livello vediamo che scherza
devo fargli loro fratello ha paura dei
riferimenti togliamo la conferma
entriamo nella casa e prende il serpente
di plastica dal comodino e mettilo sul
divano dove non mi ricordo che dobbiamo
andare dal comodino dove forse la cosa
[Applauso]
eccolo vengono ok ho preso il serpente
devo ammetterlo nel divano nel frattempo
qui potete vedere niente km come uscire
adesso da vedere davide questo modo
giusto in tempo
ok ora proviamo a rientrare in cattedra
viene un po di ansia come scheri teacher
tale da qua che possiamo stampa
mettiamo sempre tesi che mi serve bene
tema così lo vede si sta perdendo anche
aiuto che presentavano
ok riproviamo questa volta prova vitale
mia moglie da fa rumore sera era in una
di queste porte farcela prima assorbente
aspetta lui e nel divano vedi qui quindi
non possiamo andare lì adesso dobbiamo
aspettare che si sposti perché in questo
gioco come scarificio bisogna anche
stare attenti alle telecamere vedere si
sta spostando dall'altra parte della
scala deve farlo adesso
metti che io nostra pasta un po scappa
scappa stato scappa scappa scatto sta
arrivando che siamo scappati fuori ora
speriamo che lui vada a sedersi nel
divano con sapendo aspettiamo dannato
sta andando
eccolo
facciamo che farò pagare per questo in
realtà io il cattivo che vediamo con il
prossimo scherzo allora vuoi rovinare la
torta di mele i rom sull urlare prendi
la scatola e mettila dietro la sua porta
prendi la torta dal frigo e taglierà nel
pavimento della cucina o che cosa
conclude porteresti mangiarti la vera
non buttarla si sprecano
allora dove sarà la cucina allora
bisogna mettere la scatola fuori dalla
stanza del fratello cattivo sarà su
non lo so non siamo mai saliti solo
infatti bisogna fare attenzione anche
dove lui adesso è alla finestra forse
qui la sua stanza questo era il bagno ok
ok abbiamo messo la scatola fuori dalla
sua porta ora dovremo prendere la torta
davoli di predico vediamo se mosca male
non possono garantire
eccolo ai apre il frigo enorme di tutto
ha quindi lo devo buttare sull'ordinato
ma che cosa facilissima ai buttaccio
solo una fetta scappa ok siamo usciti
fuori
vediamo ha detto che ci insegnerà ci
darà una lezione che questa tesi che non
ci dimenticheremo 1 al prossimo livello
hai mai visto ron proprio impatto
fantasma no allora facciamolo taglia
questo foglio a forma di fantasma e
appendi lo sul sull'abruzzo vicino alla
porta d'entrata call center come che
abbiamo vicino di questa notte si è
inventato una gomma e vista
eccolo qui prendiamo subito il foglio la
forbice comunque divertente questo gioco
invece ok loro italiano e prendo il
fantasma mettere in qua l'entrata casta
fa restare o no tondo devi metterlo 4
bene allora la capanna in quello di
fronte
ok
[Musica]
lui sta arrivando sta arrivando ok messo
a maranello scappare velocissimamente da
qualche parte ecco la fortuna come
comunque si perfida di questo gioco
prossimo livello ron adora giocare ai
videogiochi
quindi andiamo lì fastidio e mettiamo
una trappola sopra la porta della cucina
della casa e prendere il controllo
singer suo gioco per un po di tempo
insomma quindi dobbiamo nascondere gli
insomma i joystick
allora prima devo prendere la trappola
si che stava sotto le strale
ok presa dove le dobbiamo mettere allora
sulla porta principale della cucina ok
eccola qui qui qui
ok ho messa la trappola adesso andiamo a
prendere il joystick che cattivi presagi
che affianca l'attività stessa prossimo
scherzo vediamo al trono dei fiori
peperoncino sotto loro geni l'ultimo
desiderio di roma è stata un sacco di
pizza facciamo qualcosa di divertente
siccome non ha fame e l'italia facendo
la pizza prendi dei peperoncini e
mischia lì nella pizza di rom miui piave
ma se poi la comedy caso piccante ma
siamo iper super mega pica carabi ecco
la pizza pizza
ok andiamo innanzitutto a prendere il
peperoncino giorno tra l'altro anche noi
abbiamo peroncini fatti non assomigliano
tantissimo presente però su entra
identica ma si tanto mi sta salendo al
piano di sopra quindi meno male allora
la pizza e in cucina dove era una cucina
qua qua sulla destra qui questa 996
piccola pizza mettiamo invero in sinni
deliziosa fondo lui entra d'acqua da che
potete foto da qualsiasi è stato deciso
dalle scale ok allora ridarti da allora
fa scendendo da stato fiscale
no perché potevamo puntare anche di
quale lo manda via
ok forse ma non mi troverà non posso
uccidersi ha le corna trovata alberto
per controllare caso mai avevamo messo
qualche trappola t t peperoncini sopra
hanno una cosa e ne sono accorto fuoco
ha definito nonno francini la pizza
[Musica]
allora c'è scritto solo lui state che
vuol dire ricompensa ragazzo incredibile
abbiamo già finito il gioco era
facilissimo pensavamo ci sono molti più
livelli invece l'abbiamo già finita
erano solo otto livelli
la super divertente magari la prossima
volta possiamo completare scheri
teachers e questo video reso il 30 mila
mi piace completeremo scritti c'era la
faremo a voi e poi vediamo quale scherzo
è piaciuto di più di questi il mio
scherzo preferito è stato quello della
preparazione della pizza è stato troppo
divertente
io quello del serpente perché non hai
alcun precedente all marino anche quello
del fantasma si formeranno però è il
vostro preferito invece scrivetecelo nei
commenti
ora vi lasciamo 4 caselli esco ed il
care per vedere i nostri altri video
cliccate su quella che preferite a
imparare insieme